je ne vous entends
pas arrivé en fanfare pour les candidate
depuis 1911 la commune de Rambouillet ne
Déroche pas à sa traditionnelle Nuit du
muguet pour cette édition 2024 cette
prétendantes sont en liste pour devenir
Ren ici pas de critère physique mais
l'importance de transmettre des valeurs
de solidarité à travers une association
de la commune chacune d'entre elles
représente finalement ce qu'est le
bénévolat la convivialité le
rassemblement des personnes entre elles
c'est aussi et bien les valeurs de la
jeunesse qui supporte la ville de
Rambouillet je suis totalement
stressée ça se voit pas bon j'espère je
suis totalement stressée je sais pas
quoi dire aux autres tables mais on
espère juste que que tout se passe bien
et puis que la meilleure gagne comme
pour un concours de beauté classique
chaque candidate doit savoir se
présenter en public une salle remplie
d'environ 450 personnes qu'il faut
convaincre de voter pour elle
22 ans chanteuse et musicienne
représente l'association des commerçants
de Rambouillet elle se définit comme une
personne organisé désireuse de se mettre
au service de la jeunesse de la commune
j'ai grandi ici et et voilà
ça ça fait partie de moi et et pouvoir
représenter cette ville et en être fier
avec l'association qui met à cur aussi
c'est
numro moment du dépouillement une étape
solennelle pour ce concours les
bulletins de la salle sont ajoutés au
vote de la presse locale et d'Internet
soit près de 6000 voix et la reine du
mug
représente l'association des commerçants
[Applaudissements]
et Andri nina est élu 96e reine du
muguet ce samedi 27 janvier elle succède
à Jessica gag de l'édition 2023 elle
sera accompagnée par ses de dauphines m
Germain je su vraiment très surprise ça
fait vraiment très plaisir et c'est
surtout de la joie je su vraim très
heureuse prochain rendez-vous pour la
nouvelle reine son couronnement il aura
li rouiller en mai prochain lors des
festivités de la Fête du muget